today on the matt walsh show the fbi is
now arresting trump supporters for
posting memes
yes that's happening also five headlines
including the drama on the stock market
and harriet tubman replacing andrew
jackson on the 20.
and our daily cancellation we'll discuss
the instagram baby expert who was
doxxed harassed and boycotted after was
revealed that she had committed the
crime of donating to donald trump
that and a whole lot more to cover today
on the matt wall show
the fbi apparently having finished its
investigation into bubba wallace's
garage door pull and looking for a new
dragon to slay showed up yesterday at
the home
of a trump supporting former twitter
troll and took him into custody on
charges of as a press release from the
doj puts it
depriving individuals of their
constitutional right to vote
the formal criminal complaint alleges
more specifically that the accused
douglas mackey
a.k.a ricky vaughn that's the the name
of his uh
his twitter account which has been
suspended for years now
they say he conspired to quote injure
oppress
threaten and intimidate persons in the
free exercise of a right and privilege
secured to them by the constitution
the rest of the complaint makes it clear
that all of this supposed
injuring oppressing threatening and
intimidating
was conducted in the form of memes
mackey faces 10 years in federal prison
for memes
now admittedly it's not a great shock i
guess to find joe biden's government
arresting and prosecuting people for
posting memes if there's any surprise
here it's perhaps
only that it took less than two weeks to
get to this point
the new york times has some more details
on the case they say federal prosecutors
accuse douglas mackie 31 of
coordinating with co-conspirators to
spread memes on twitter
falsely claiming that hillary clinton
supporters could vote by sending a text
message to a specific phone number
as a result of the misinformation
campaign prosecutors said at least 4 900
people
or rather 4 900 unique phone numbers
texted the number in a futile effort to
cast votes for mrs clinton
their effort to misinform voters began
after the group saw a similar campaign
intended to deceive voters in the 2016
referendum in britain
on whether the to leave the european
union also known as brexit according to
the complaint
mr mackie and his associates created
their own version sharing photos that
urged mrs clinton supporters to vote for
her on election day
using a hashtag on twitter or on
facebook
to make the images look more legitimate
they affixed the logo of her campaign
and linked to her website
some of their memes appeared to target
black latino voters
uh one image had a black woman standing
in front of a sign supporting mrs
clinton telling people to vote for mrs
clinton by texting a specific number
mr mackey shared a similar image written
in spanish according to prosecutors
okay now back when mackie and his
dastardly co-conspirators first
hatched this plan to oppress and injure
the innocent through memes
buzzfeed published a report on the plot
which um included a screenshot of what
those 4 900 people who texted the number
apparently would have received in
response
the clinton campaign sent a reply text
because this was a text going
to the clinton campaign the clinton
campaign sent a reply text
informing them that the ad was not
legitimate
so so there is then no reason to think
that all of those 4 900 people
or any of them actually did stay home on
election day under the assumption that
they'd already voted through text
because according to buzzfeed's own
report they were given a message back
saying
that was not legitimate what you saw in
the meme words to that effect
it would seem difficult for the federal
government to prove that anyone was
deprived their right to vote when for
all they know
for all we know the alleged victims did
in fact vote
that of course is all beside the point
the real question is whether it's
actually
possible for a person to be deprived of
their rights or to be injured much less
oppressed
through a meme and the answer to that
would be seem to be no
at least if there is a meme capable of
persecuting all who look upon it
like some sort of horror movie you just
look at the image and you're oppressed
the ones that mackie posted surely do
not fit that bill i don't know what that
meme would look like i don't know what a
persecuting oppressive meme would look
like i just know that it doesn't look
like this
a constitutional right is infringed
impeded or removed when a person is
through force or threat
prevented from exercising it
nobody was prevented from doing anything
in this case
if there are any rights being infringed
upon it's the first amendment
right of douglas mackey and if any
individual was so
unfathomably stupid as to read a
joke meme on twitter and take its voting
guidance seriously
without even doing five seconds of
additional research because that's all
you would need to do
if you're dump you need to be two levels
of stupid here stupid enough to see that
and not immediately recognize it as a
joke
and then also so stupid that you don't
take five seconds to just google
can i vote through text message it's all
would have taken
and if you couldn't put in that effort
and you were that stupid
then the fault lies with you
you know now you can't always victim
blame in cases of fraud
but when the supposed quote-unquote
fraud is a silly picture on twitter
telling you to vote in a presidential
election with a hashtag
or a text message um yeah the victim
does indeed deserve the blame i am 100
victim blaming i blame the victims
totally
and also have zero sympathy for them if
anything
the alleged oppressor has done us a
favor by weeding out the sort of
terminal morons
who shouldn't be voting in the first
place i realize that's not a valid legal
defense however but um
just on a personal note i'm quite glad
anyone who's stupid enough to fall for
something like that i am happy if they
don't vote
thank god they don't vote
now consider the precedent that's quite
intentionally being set here
you know a very common joke on social
media around the time of any election is
for supporters of one candidate to
announce that the supporters of any any
other
are allowed to vote a day late or you
know something like that those jokes are
very common
you see them around election day all the
time so
is anyone who made a joke like that now
guilty of a federal crime
if you've made a joke like that on the
internet at any point in your life
are you now liable to go to jail for 10
years i mean does 10 years in prison
sound like a reasonable sentence
even if you agree that it's a crime 10
years which i don't
10 years in prison for that
and if it's now a felony to post a meme
with disinformation
that may influence voting behavior how
far does that go
i mean there are many false or dubious
political claims made in the form of
memes
almost all memes have false or dubious
information
almost everything on the internet does
are we going to prosecute everyone who
posts or retweets one
isn't that the implication here if you
even retweet
a meme that has false information that
may arguably influence the voting
behavior of some people
it's a crime go to jail
but if that's what we're doing why are
we not breaking down the doors of people
who posted claims about donald trump
being a nazi
why are we frog marching them off to
jail that's disinformation
and if believed it could very well
influence how somebody votes
of course my question is rhetorical
disinformation used against republicans
never has been and never will be
prosecuted mackey's crime
is not that he that he posted
information a disinformation or that he
infringed on anybody's right
but that he did what he did in support
of donald trump
that's the crime the only way around
this conclusion is is the only way you
could get around this
and prove me wrong is if you can point
to
leftist meme posters who have also been
arrested
or else to claim that leftists never
post dishonest memes and so that's why
they don't get arrested for them
but there are no examples of the former
and anyone who claims the latter is
guilty of disinformation themselves in
fact
just to prove my point here here is one
example that
this just came to my attention right
before we went on the air um christina
wong
she's an alleged comedian i think
there's some disinformation
in that claim alone but let me show you
a video that
she posted on twitter this is on
november 8th
2016. here's what she posted watch hey
everybody this is christina wong
and uh i'm coming out i'm a trump
supporter
and i just want to remind all my fellow
chinese americans for trump
people of color for trump to vote vote
for trump
on wednesday november 9th really
important day we're going to show this
country
who's boss and that's our man donald
trump so don't forget to vote donald
trump
on november 9th
huh huh
see as far as i'm aware miss wong has
not been raided by the fbi there are no
30 page criminal complaints
being filed against this woman
and that's all you need to know i mean
that that if if there was any doubt in
your mind whatsoever about whether or
not
this new policy this new law is being uh
is being enforced equally well there you
go
and we could sit here all day posting
give you similar examples similar jokes
like that
all kinds of disinformation related to
donald trump
much of it not even coming in the form
of means memes but coming from the media
coming in the form of headlines news
articles stories
we're not prosecuting any of that and
that's because
there is there has been for a long time
and will especially be now a two-tiered
justice system
there's the justice system for the
cultural heretics
and if you're on the right then that's
where you belong you're a cultural
heretic
there's just system for people like uh
miss wong there
someone who has the correct who believes
in the correct orthodoxy
who has the correct views there's a lot
of things she can do
that you cannot anymore because you'll
go to prison
and saying there's a two-tiered justice
system where we have two-tiered justice
that's just another way of saying
we don't have justice in the country
this country there is no justice there
is no law
there is but the whims of the elite
and that's the way it's going to go now
anyone who's not
who has not woken up to that reality
time to wake up now let's get to our
five headlines
[Music]
now you've uh no doubt heard what's
happening
with wall street the stock market game
stop
if you haven't heard well unfortunately
i'm too dumb to explain
so you're kind of out of luck but let me
uh i'll read this
this is one of the lasers from reuters
um the latest on all of this
says it almost 60 percent surge in
shares of american airlines
uh led stellar led stellar gains for a
series of social media hype stocks on
thursday broadening a battle between
small-time traders and major wall street
institutions
that has shaken u.s and european stock
markets gamestop the video game chain
whose uh
1700 rally has been at the heart of the
slugfest in the past week
retreated after initially adding another
30 in early trading
on reddit that you could tell when i'm
reading this i have very little idea
what i'm even reading i think that comes
through doesn't it
on reddit on a reddit thread wall street
bets where calls to buy stocks have
helped drive the extraordinary moves
some of its more than four million
members reported trading platform robin
hood was now preventing
investors from buying new shares in
gamestop and
um and other companies robinhood one of
the biggest of the easy access
apps that has spurred the development of
a huge online community of amateur
traders did not immediately respond to
requests for comment
so now they're preventing it that now if
i could just break this down
everything that's happening on the stock
market if you don't understand and i
could really break it down for you
um just just to simplify let me explain
so basically what's happening is um
just to make it really simple if i were
to really break this down
and really simplify everything and if
i'm going to actually explain it
you know there's a number of things that
i would say to explain it
because i totally understand i do
but in fact it's too complicated i can't
explain it i'm not gonna bother
let's go to the white house press
conference though um
the question was asked about all of this
and even though
i admit i don't understand much about
the stock market or anything at all
really i can listen to this answer
and i can tell that this is completely
bogus and ridiculous let's listen
is the way i was concerned about the
stock market activity we're seeing
around game stop
um and now with some other stocks as
well including
the subsidiary or whatever the company
that was
a blockbuster and have there been any
conversations with the
sec about how to proceed
well i'm also happy to repeat that we
have the first female treasury secretary
and a team that's surrounding her and
often questions about market we'll send
to them but our team is of course our
economic team including
secretary yellen and others are
monitoring the situation it's a good
reminder though that the stock market
isn't the only measure of the health of
our econo
our economy doesn't reflect how working
and middle class families are doing
as you all know from covering this we're
in the midst of a k-shape recovery
america's workers are struggling to make
ends meet which is why the president has
introduced this urgent package to get
immediate relief
yeah like i said um not a financial
expert myself but i'm pretty sure
that the gender of the treasury
secretary has nothing to do
with anything whatsoever
so i i can point out that bs at least
this kind of goes back to what we were
talking about before but you think about
how stupid you have to be
to fall for the the memes right even if
you even if you don't know anything
about voting at all
right um you should still be able to
pick up on
obvious bs even if you know nothing
about the subject if you have even
just a a a moderately well-tuned bs
detector
you should be able to pick up on a joke
meme
and so in this case don't know anything
about the stock market i've got
at least a moderately tuned uh bs
detector so i can listen to that answer
and no okay that's that's
that's of ridiculous
has nothing to do with anything what i
will say if i were to give any analysis
whatsoever what's happening on the stock
market i don't know much
i do think it's funny as far as i can
tell it seems pretty funny and that's
all i've got
that's all i can tell you let's move on
to something i know a little bit more
about
staying with the white house press
briefing for a moment uh this is from a
couple of days ago i've been wanting to
bring this up the question
being asked here is about the plan to
put harriet tubman
um on the 20 bill which means taking
andrew jackson
off putting her on let's listen to that
the obama administration initially had
wanted to
put harriet tubman on the 20 bill
um the trump administration draws their
feet on that
i wanted to see if the biden
administration has a
sort of view of the timeline on whether
or not she should be
on the paper currency i was here when we
when we announced that and it was very
exciting it hasn't moved forward yet
which we would have been surprised to
learn at the time
the treasury department is taking steps
to resume efforts to put harriet tubman
on the front of the
new 20 notes it's important
that our notes are our money of
people don't know what a note is reflect
the history and diversity of our country
and harriet tubman's image gracing the
new 20 note would
certainly reflect that so we're
exploring ways to speed up that effort
but
any specifics would of course come from
the department of treasury
so this is the kind of thing that we're
all supposed to simply support
without any protests and of course we
don't support it then you're racist
and i have been disappointed though not
surprised to find so many conservatives
of course
going along with this and and say oh i
don't
i would never object i would maybe some
would object to this but i
certainly would not but harry would talk
about that put her on all the money
of course go ahead well we should honor
harry tubman
they say well i agree i'm all for
honoring
harriet tubman there are many ways to do
that there are many ways that we have
honored her
there are many additional ways that we
could the point here the
the question the issue at hand is not
whether to
honor harriet tubman on that point i
think there's
probably almost universal agreement the
question is actually whether to
dishonor to take the honor away from
andrew jackson because that's actually
the point that's why the left wants to
do this
it's not about harry tubman it's about
andrew jackson
and what is it about him well it's about
it's about the fact that he was an
an old white guy that lived a long time
ago and we have learned that
if you belong to that category or if you
belong to that category
then um you have to be erased from the
history books and you're not allowed to
be honored in any way it's a way
whatsoever
this is not it's not like andrew jacks
is the only one they're targeting
in fact maybe talk more about this
tomorrow but san francisco school board
the latest one
uh it's decided to rename i think it's
something like 40 different schools
including lincoln high school washington
they got a school named after washington
taking those down too so eventually
you know eventually we're gonna be
taking all the other money's gonna be
changed too
taking their faces off the money as well
but that's what this is about so when i
say i'm not in favor of putting
harriet tubman on the 20 what i really
mean is i'm not in favor of taking
andrew jackson off
because i believe he was a great and
consequential american
doesn't mean i think he was a saint in
all respects doesn't mean that i think
he was
perfect but most great people
are not in fact no great people are are
or were
except for jesus christ anyone outside
of that
not perfect and in fact the thing we
know about great and consequential
people
is that they often have great
inconsequential flaws as well
that's when when you are operating on a
certain level
you know your your virtues are going to
be magnified
but your vices are also going to be
magnified that's the way it goes
that's why i always talk about if we're
going to hold if this is the standard
we're applying
to one person who lived back in history
to one historical figure then really you
have to apply it to everyone which means
eventually there's going to be nobody
left of any race
nation creed or gender that we can honor
if they lived
you know if they lived like 10 years ago
or earlier
there's no one left who isn't
problematic so no we
this this is something we should be
against and we should we should protest
we should we should be again we should
oppose this
taking andrew jackson off you want to
come up with a with a
uh a new a new currency
for harriet tubman or and really
anything else builder
she's already got statues and monuments
build another one build 50 of them for
all i care
andrew jackson should stay on the 20
bill
to my mind all right abc 7 new york has
this story it says target is the latest
company to drop
um chalco i think it's choco
coconut milk over allegations of forced
monkey labor
peta said the retailer will no longer
sell the product because of its alleged
ties to monkey labor
chaoco's thai supplier is accused of
forcing monkeys to pick coconuts from
the trees
in a statement to usa today target said
it takes those claims seriously and
remove the product in november
um peta said in a statement by dropping
chalco target is joining thousands of
stores that refuse to profit from
chained monkey's misery
according to peta 2600 26 000 rather
stores including chains wegmans food
lion and stop and shop have cut ties
with the coconut milk brand a couple
things here first of all
as i've made clear coconut milk is not
actually a thing doesn't doesn't exist
you don't you don't get milk is a dairy
product you don't get that from uh
from coconuts second thing is forced
monkey labor i i never realized that was
a thing
until i read this story and also
speaking of dairy products okay so you
hear i
i don't know what exactly could be
entailed
in forced monkey labor how do you force
monkeys to
climb a tree and pick coconuts um
you know i guess you could domesticate
domesticate monkeys like you do any
other animal
but that's the point so
forced monkey labor is if that's what's
happening here
forest monkey labor is some sort of
horrible crime
so you're not gonna have coconut milk
but you'll still serve regular milk
which comes from cows is what about
forced
cow labor cows cows don't make the free
choice to be on dairy farms do they
what about the forced laborers of labor
of horses and
and pigs and dogs
all that for it's all slavery isn't it
we just we have this hierarchy in our
heads of animals
it's like there's certain animals you
could eat certain that you can't certain
you can domesticate certain you can't
a lot of it has to do with how cute we
think they are
or how much we have anthropomorphized
them in our own minds
um how often they appear in disney films
like these all these things factor in
and this is what determines in our heads
what we can do with these different
animals
it's not really based in anything though
so yes i think i'm coming out in favor
of forced monkey labor i think i think
i'm okay with it honestly
i don't know a lot about the practice
i'm not in favor of you know
abusing monkeys i wouldn't be in favor
of using cows
and really when you think about it yeah
if if you're you know
a poor villager and you harvest coconuts
for a living well you got to get up you
might not have
uh equipment to get up in those trees
and you pretty get up pretty high in the
trees um which is a
dangerous job and so someone's got to
climb up in the trees to get the
coconuts i think i'd rather
a monkey be forced to do it rather than
a person because a person could climb up
there and fall and
die sure that happens all the time
so yeah you could put me in the put me
in the column of
pro-forced monkey labor um
all right this is from eater.com it says
in line with one of president joe
biden's chief campaign promises
congressional democrats yesterday
introduced historic legislation this is
from a couple days ago that would
more than double the hourly minimum wage
of the country's
most poorly paid workers to 15
an hour uh the measure would also
eventually eliminate the lower tipped
minimum wage that most waiters
bartenders and busers earn in new york
and other states
despite republican opposition a process
known as budget reconciliation appears
to give the so-called raise the wage act
the chance of being signed into law
so 15 an hour this is just uh
of course we've we we've known about
this effort for a long time
will the democrats actually manage to
pass it through um
i would say yes probably and the effects
will be
absolutely disastrous you look at what
the democrats are doing here
um already they've they have
largely we're talking about democrat
governors and mayors who have had the
strictest lockdowns
in effect still in effect in many places
uh for
almost a year now and so they've wiped
out millions of jobs
and now we're just sort of trying to
claw back get the economy back people
are trying to get back to work
vaccines being rolled out we're going to
get into spring in the warmer months
and now they're coming back and they're
kneecapping all the economy again
we're shutting down the keystone
pipeline and now we're going to 15
minimum wage wipe out
thousands of jobs all at once
that's why i i really wish you talk
about the effects of disinformation
i don't really care about memes but the
kind of disinformation that i worry
about
is for example the disinformation that
makes someone who's let's say a minimum
wage worker
and they read about raising minimum wage
because they have been influenced by
disinformation from the media
they celebrate it they say oh this is
going to be great i'm going to make 15
an hour no
what they don't understand is that this
probably means that you're not gonna
have a job
you're gonna go from whatever you're
making now ten dollars an hour uh to
zero
that's what's gonna happen
whether you work for a big company or
small company small company
small businesses especially that have
been that have been in particularly
devastated by
the lockdowns they're not going to have
the money to to
automatically overnight raise all these
wages so they're going to have to cut
down their labor force
if you work at a place like mcdonald's
already you go into a mcdonald's
and um the common experience now is that
there are a couple of people behind
the cash registers and then they've also
got the the touch screens
and so what's mcdonald's gonna do
they're gonna say okay well we'll just
we'll go to all touch screen
we don't even need the people at the
yeah you can insert the money or your
credit card into the
into the uh the console there what do we
need we don't even need anybody there
all we need are people some people in
the back to cook the food and maybe we
need some people working the drive
through but we don't need anybody
so these jobs are just going to get
eliminated
the other thing to keep in mind with um
with the minimum wage
and this is always lost in the the
conversation but
first of all a very small number of
hourly workers in america are actually
getting paid
the federal minimum wage almost all
people who are hourly workers in america
are getting paid more than minimum wage
already
but i don't have the numbers in front of
me the percentage is small it's like two
or three percent
of hourly workers that are getting paid
the minimum wage
many of those workers are young many of
them are teenagers
uh many of them at least are under 25
it's not the way this this the the
minimum wage
is is talked about this issue is
discussed they make it sound like there
are
millions of of families you know mothers
and fathers who got kids to feed
families of five that are trying to
subsist on minimum wages which is why
we're told it has to be a living wage we
have to give them a living which
that's not the case
in in many many cases this again is a
small minority of hourly
workers and in many many cases these are
people you know these these could be
kids
college students don't even pay their
own bills they have no dependents
they're not even independent themselves
they don't need a living wage
the companies can't afford them to pay a
living wage
the labor they're providing is not
really worth
15 an hour
but now you're going to say oh yeah you
got to pay 15 an hour to the sick to the
17 year old kid who lives at home and is
working part time at mcdonald's we got
to pay
him 15 an hour and the price is we're
going to wipe out thousands of jobs
great idea all right uh number five the
chicago's teachers union which is
refusing to go back to work has been um
using its free time
free time free time but paid time
taxpayers are paying for it to do other
things and in this case interpretive
dance routines so they tweeted this out
they said six of our rank and file dance
teachers
come together to use their art form as a
voice to express their desire to feel
safe
amidst cps's teacher return policy
they stand in solidarity with all
educators at risk because no one should
have to choose between life and
livelihood
i think we have that video let's let's
play a little bit of this
interpretive dance routine
i will survive so these are these are
dance teachers now you know what this is
this is like some sort of hideous super
organism where you've got a combination
of the dance we what we have now is a
combination of the dancing
nurses on tick tock and the whiny
teachers and they've come together
to form the super organism
and now we have whiny dancing teachers
i also have to say these are these are
this tells you something about the
public school system i guess
[Music]
these are dance first of all why do we
have dance teachers in the public school
system to begin with
and second question if we do have dance
teachers who's that what the person in
the middle what are they doing
it's not a dance at all i could do that
if we do have dance teachers in the
public school system why is it that they
can't dance
seems to me interpretive dance is is uh
kind of like slam poetry
in that you know slam poetry isn't
poetry at all interpretive dance is not
dance at all
interpretive dance is just a mildly
artistic seizure
from what i can tell people flailing
their arms around anyway
so the teachers did an interpretive
dance to express their fear of going
back to school that's
uh that's what that's all about
and i will conclude by for the millionth
time saying
get your kids out of the public school
system folks you know there's no reason
to waste your time
nobody wants to waste their time there's
no reason to do it and when you waste
time and money time is money so you
waste time you already spent you're
already wasting money and what if you're
wasting more money on top of that it's
just a mess
what i'm trying to say is use rock auto
rockauto.com is the way to go
uh it's the way to save time and save
money it's just a win-win situation
rockauto.com if you're looking for auto
parts
much easier much quicker much cheaper
than walking into an auto parts store
at rockauto.com they always offer the
lowest prices possible they're not going
to change the prices just because they
think they can
make more money off you it's not nothing
like that what you know you have the
peace of mind when you go to
rockauto.com you know that
you're getting the cheapest possible
price for this particular part
that you're gonna find anywhere there's
no reason to look anywhere else this is
the best you're gonna get
uh and often you know it's it's really
quite quite affordable rockauto.com is a
family business they've been serving
auto parts customers online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
best of all again rockauto.com prices
that are reliably low
and they're the same for professionals
and do-it-yourselfers on top of all that
great selection everything you could
possibly need and very easy to find over
at rockauto.com so go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck and remember to
write walsh in there how did you hear
about his box
so they know where you came from all
right and also daily wire of course is
in this effort of fighting to take back
the culture and a big part of that
is about entertainment you know it's
about creating culture
rather than simply commenting on it we
want to do both over here
and that's where uh run hide fight comes
from run hide fight is our
movie you've heard a lot about it you've
heard us talking about it and um
don't don't trust us though don't listen
to what we have to say you can go to
rotten tomatoes you can see it's got a
93
rating with over 2 000 reviews the
audience loves it
mainstream critics maybe they don't like
it quite as much i think they're they're
scandalized by it they think it's
distasteful they don't like that we're
attached to it
but the audience likes it so if you want
to watch our latest film
our first film with many more to come
use promo code rhf to get 25
off that's rhf for 25 off again rhf 25
off and become a daily wire member today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
so today we have another reverse
cancellation the cancelers will become
the cancelled
and as we get into the story if there's
any sincere person left in america who
still
thinks that cancel culture is a myth
doesn't exist
they may want to pay attention and
seriously consider the case of kara
dumaplin
she's a popular baby sleep training
expert who you know i hadn't heard of
before this but uh
apparently very popular and she has been
ruthlessly attacked
boycotted doxxed and smeared over the
past week
after someone will have more on that
someone in a moment went through fec
records and discovered that she donated
to donald trump they went through the
records and found this out
now many media outlets have reported on
the story eager to amplify the news of a
non-political person's private campaign
contributions and most of the coverage
has been along the lines of this
headline from the cut which is a new
york magazine publication
they say quote a boycott is brewing
against formerly beloved child care
consultant kara dumaplin
who has reportedly been funneling some
of the profits from her pricey classes
into the trump campaign's coffers
now this is disgraceful of course and
also not true
not only are they straining to make
donations sound sinister by using a
phrase like
funneling the profits but they assume
that the money
that's was being given to the trump
campaign came from her child care
consultant business
but we have no way of knowing that we
don't know where the money came from
she has a husband apparently who works
he's a doctor going to come from him
and it doesn't matter anyway kara
dumaplin
offers advice on how to care for infants
very good advice i have been
told she she never chose to publicize
her personal views
the small amount of money she donated to
a political campaign about a thousand
dollars
a thousand dollars over the course of
three years which is what she said in a
statement to the today show
that's of no one's concern but her own
this is not a case of a public person
choosing to air their political views
and then experiencing the divided
response that any sane person must
expect at this point
this is rather a woman in a completely
apolitical line of work
whose financial records along with her
address have been dug up and published
in order to personally destroy her
in an act of collective ideological
vengeance
it's cancelled culture that's what
cancer culture is
hit pieces in the media claim that moms
across america have somehow been
betrayed they feel betrayed because a
woman who gave them advice on how to
help their infants sleep happens to hold
political views that don't align with
their own
sophia tesfay uh in salon
she wrote an article openly admitting
that this is another case of cancel
culture but she says that it's good
it's a good thing because it holds
dumaplin accountable for the sin of
possessing a mind and forming opinions
of her own
by the way if you're wondering if you're
not familiar with this woman and
you're wondering what sort of content
this right-wing extremist was putting
out there
um here just as a quick example give you
a frame of reference
uh this this this this dangerous person
who has to be held accountable this
right-wing extremist
here she is this is sort of typical
content that she would put out here she
is explaining how to properly burp a
newborn this this is the woman
that is right now the target of of
public rage let's let's listen
lots of times i see parents when they
try to burp they put her right
here like this and they do this and
they're trying to burp but she's just
not burping
so here's what i want to show you take
her and put her little chest
up and over your shoulder like this and
then cup your hand make a c like this
you want to hear it hear that that
doesn't hurt her
but hear how you can hear that noise
that's what's going to get your burp out
sometimes parents do this and it just
doesn't get up about you want to cup it
so it doesn't hurt her back and just go
like this so that's one method
is up over the shoulder again get her
chest up and over your shoulder like
that
wow what an extremist
good advice on the burping though by the
way my favorite method though is you sit
the baby up i think she gets into this
you sit the baby up and hold them sort
of by the chin and then pat them on the
back i think it gets the burp out a
little bit better but anyway
that's what uh that's the kind of that's
it that's that's what she does she just
tells you how to care for babies
um i i am not aware of any video that
she's ever put out
advocating for a candidate or anything
like that
now the guy who seems to have gotten the
cancel ball rolling in this case uh his
name is jamie grayson
and he's a fellow parenting influencer
on instagram
and he quite clearly saw this as an
opportunity to kneecap his instagram
competition
he's the one who first published or he's
one of the original ones who first
published dumaclin's fec records
which include her address again along
with a lengthy screed promising that
he's a quote very liberal homosexual
male
he doesn't hold any of her heretical
views not me i'm not
i'm not like her and other vultures from
the mommy and daddy blogger sphere
swooped in to get a piece of the carcass
and that's that's how this all started
this is one of the the primary hallmarks
of cancel culture
it's how you diff differentiate it from
your average boycott or a genuine case
of holding somebody accountable
the people who are looking to obscure
this issue that's what they'll always
try to equate these things with and they
say well you know it's just a regular
boycott it's holding someone accountable
now this is how you tell the difference
because in cancel culture it's always
vindictive
and contemptuous and often the bus is
being driven by someone who stands to
personally gain from the destruction of
the person
who's being thrown under it that's not
to say that the average member of the
outrage mob
you know the moms claiming to be
betrayed and vowing never to use this
child care program again
have self-serving motivations i don't
think they do they're more like
maniacs driven to the edge of insanity
by hatred for their fellow americans
and by their fear of people who think
differently from themselves
just consider for a moment what they're
actually doing here i'm talking about
the average person and i was going
through some of the comments
uh and it was a dark and twisted journey
reading some of the comments of of
former fans of this woman who now say oh
i'm done i can't i'm not going to
use the program anymore assuming they
follow through on their boycott threats
think about what they're doing because
dumaplin by all accounts
is a miracle worker in the field of baby
sleep training that's her expertise
um over the last day i've spoken to a
number of people who swear by her
methods
say it's a lifesaver then anyone who's
had an infant who struggles to sleep
knows that it can just about wreck your
life at least for as long as the
nighttime struggle sessions continue
we have been through this with a few of
our kids it is it is
very very difficult because it turns out
that sleep is a rather crucial human
need
when you're being deprived of it you
become desperate pretty quickly
there's a reason that sleep deprivation
is considered a form of torture
according to the geneva convention
whether infants are therefore guilty of
human rights abuses as a legal question
for another time but
what all this means is that these
betrayed mothers
will choose now to suffer with a
sleepless baby
rather than use the methods and the
advice of a woman who donated to donald
trump
they are choosing ideology over their
own health and sanity
and they don't have much of the latter
despair to begin with
it makes you wonder whether these people
would intentionally die of thirst if a
trump supporter recommended they drink
water
as this episode shows cancel culture
itself is not
the underlying problem it's real but
it's not
the problem it's not the problem it is a
symptom
the disease is a world view that cannot
tolerate
any form of dissent from anyone it sees
all things in a political light it sees
all people as political entities
it sees anyone outside of its tribe as
an enemy worthy of condemnation and
worse
it clamors for diversity but seeks a
world of sameness
it demands tolerance but never returns
the favor
cancel culture emerges inevitably from
this
hateful ideology otherwise known as
leftism
and as we have seen no one not even this
woman is exempt from its wrath
and that's why the cancellers are
cancelled and by the way quick pitch for
her
unpaid uh if you're looking for advice
on how to get a baby to sleep
maybe this is a woman you should support
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledosky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021. internet
trolls bankrupt hedge funds for the laws
john kerry tells fossil fuel workers to
learn solar
and most republicans support trump in
2024.
check it out on the michael knowles show
[Music]